bonsoir gérald olivier merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france c'est pas la première
fois que les états unis
on perd un bras de fer avec la cpi ne
sont pas signataires
quelle est l'analyse de cette situation
aujourd'hui pourquoi ces représailles de
washington bon on fait tourner dans la
continuation d'un processus qui a
commencé il ya une vingtaine d'années à
vous savez le le statut de rome qui a
donné naissance à ces la cpi on dit en
français il a été signé par le président
américain à l'époque ça n'a jamais été
ratifié par le sénat et le président
bush s'est même a même retiré la
signature américaine donc les états unis
n'ont jamais reconnu la légitimité de la
cpi
et quand barack obama est arrivé au
pouvoir il n'a rien fait pour que cette
légitimité soit reconnu et il l'a fait
en accord avec ses deux secrétaires
d'état de l'époque avec hillary clinton
d'abord avec john kerry par la suite
donc les américains que ce soit d
administration démocrate ou des
administrations républicaines ne
reconnaissent pas la légitimité de cette
cour est donc il considère que ces
interventions sont de l'ingérence dans
les affaires intérieures des états unis
et ça il ne le supporte pas donc ils
refusent que quiconque vienne enquêter
chez eux ou même sur leurs crimes de
guerre il faut souligner au passage que
20 potentiel crimes de guerre faut
souligner au passage que les états unis
sont pas du tout isolé dans leur posture
la cpi est reconnu par l'union
européenne elle est reconnue je crois
par 130 pays au sein de l'onu mais la
chine n'est pas signataire
l'inde n'est pas signataire la russie
n'est pas signataire
donc vous avez quand même trois ou
quatre avec les états unis israël n'est
pas signataire non plus mais les plus
importantes puissances mondiales n'ont
pas forcément reconnu la légitimité de
cette cour et ne souhaite pas qu'elle
vienne enquêter chez eux
les etats unis font partie de ce groupe
et c'est une position qui était connue
depuis un certain nombre d'années
donc concrètement si les états unis ne
sont pas signataires
ils ne risquent rien à quoi ça sert
d'enquêter sur ces crimes présumés en
afghanistan de la part des soldats ou de
la cia par exemple mais ça c'est une
très bonne question mais à mon avis elle
touche beaucoup plus
à la cour elle même et à sa
justification
vous savez que depuis depuis 2002 cette
cour est dirigée par une procureure en
gambienne madame bensouda fatou bensouda
je pense elle n'a pas eu beaucoup de
succès depuis qu'elle est arrivée à son
poste
elle a même connu un certain fiasco
puisque en pratiquement 20 ans le seul
grand personnage veut dire chefs d'état
qu'ils ont réussi à mettre en procès a
été laurent gbagbo à partir de 2010 il
ya eu sept ou huit enquêtes
d'investigation et tout ça s'est terminé
par un acquittement temps le dossier du
procureur et de son équipe était faible
depuis monsieur gbagbo est toujours
maintenue comment dirais-je en liberté
surveillée il ya eu appel mais il
n'empêche que la cour pénale
internationale n'a pas eu beaucoup de
succès et donc sa légitimité en fête
risque d'être remise en cause
et derrière la volonté de madame
bensouda du procureur d'aller au delà
des chefs d'état africains c'est un
moyen de renforcer cette légitimité donc
on va aller regarder du côté de l'irak
on va aller regarder du côté de
l'afghanistan
il pourrait aussi elle a gardé de la
syrie il pourrait aussi aller regarder
du côté de la chine
pourquoi ne vont-ils pas regardé en
corée du nord il ya une sorte de
sélection ici qui est assez orienté mais
à la vérité je pense que c'est le statut
même de la cour qui est beaucoup plus
fragile que la position américaine sur
ce dossier
est-ce que ça contribue néanmoins à
faire de la mauvaise publicité on sait
que bientôt le le dossier palestinien
sur la colonisation des territoires
palestiniens sera sera d'actualité
sagem washington néanmoins vous pensé en
termes d'image non pas du tout d'abord
parce que d'un trempe aime bien être le
seul contre tous c'est une position qui
l'affectent
et puis vous savez que
les relations internationales c'est pas
quelqu'un qui a fait beaucoup de bien à
l'onu unis qui a reconnu la légitimité
de ses institutions
là il est en train de critiquer la cpi
accord auquel ils n'ont jamais adhéré
mais les états unis sous la dalle trump
se sont retirés de la commission des
droits de l'homme de des nations unies
ils se sont retirés de l'accord iranien
qui avait été au départ organisé autour
d'une résolution du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies en 2015 ils se sont
retirés de l'accord international de
paris sur le climat ils viennent de se
retirer de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
donc vous avez d'une série d'actions ou
les états unis préfèrent un être seul
être libre et traités avec leurs alliés
ou leurs rivaux anna de manille dans
bilatérales et l'action qu'ils viennent
de prendre le décret qui a été signé et
qui est un décret très dur et très
étendu et il faut le souligner
d'ailleurs vous l'avez très bien dit
dans votre reportage s'est pas seulement
les membres de la cour qui sont
concernées mais c'est tout les associés
ou les partenaires qui pourraient être
amenés à travailler avec eux il ya une
sorte de sanction par association qui
pénalise véritablement dans son
fonctionnement la cour mais dans cette
attitude encore une fois les états unis
sont tout à fait logique avec avec
eux-mêmes et monsieur tremblay tout à
fait cohérent avec sa politique qui a
toujours privilégié des relations
bilatérales aux relations multilatérales
merci beaucoup gérald olivier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur arte france